SHEKHAR BAPAT: Hello.
I'm Shekhar Bapat.
I'm the product manager
for Data Catalog
working for Google Cloud.
And I'm here to talk about
Data Catalog for data discovery
and metadata management.
I'm going to be joined by
Shruti Thaker from BlackRock
towards the end of
the presentation,
and she's going to share
their experience using Data
Catalog for BlackRock purposes.
So what is Data Catalog?
Data Catalog,
simply put, enables
users to discover,
understand, and manage
all their data assets.
So Data Catalog-- when
we released it in beta,
we got a lot of feedback from
customers, where they said,
this is great.
This is like Google Search
for my enterprise data assets.
But they told us that that
data sets are not only in GCP,
but they are spread
across multiple silos.
Some on them, some
on other clouds.
And they wanted us to
help them discover data
across all of their data silos.
They wanted one unified
single pane of glass.
And that is what we
deliver here today,
an enterprise data catalog.
But before I go into the details
of the Data Catalog service,
I want to talk a little
bit about the genesis.
Google feels this problem
of too many data assets
and how to discover
the valued data assets
way before other companies did.
And so Google internally
built a data catalog,
and that data catalog is
a very scalable system.
It indexes more than
100 million entries
and has been used actively by
tens of thousands of Googlers.
Google also published
a paper on this.
It's called the GOODS paper.
We can easily find it.
The GOODS paper
outlines a number
of techniques and technologies.
So this is the backbone.
The data catalog service
I'm going to talk about
is how their initiative
externalized the system
that we built for ourselves.
If there is one
slide that captures
the essence of what Data Catalog
is today, it is this slide.
So when we started to
build the Data Catalog,
we wanted to do something
different from what
the traditional catalogs do.
The traditional
catalogs require users
to do a lot of heavy lifting.
They require users to register
their data assets explicitly,
one by one.
And the first thing we wanted to
do is to automate the process.
The goal here is to
create a smart catalog.
So Data Catalog automatically
syncs the technical metadata
from data sources like BigQuery,
Pub/Sub and Cloud Storage.
So if you did a new
table in BigQuery,
you don't need to
register anything.
Within three seconds, that
table shows up in Data Catalog.
So that's a very,
very useful feature
for a lot of our customers.
The second thing that I
want to highlight here
is the auto-tagging of PII
data through our integration
with DLP.
So our customers tell us that
they have thousands of tables,
hundreds of columns
in each table,
and often the column
names don't let on
as to whether it
has PII data or not.
So DLP, as some
of you might know,
stand for Data Loss Prevention.
It's a service in GA.
And we provide
integration with DLP
that enables you to use
DLP to scan your data.
We can do a full scan of
the data, or to save money,
you can do sample scan.
But DLP will identify the data.
It puts semantics on the data.
It says, ah, this is
not just any number.
This can be a social security
number or a credit card number.
And as it learned, it's able
to auto-detect PII data.
And DLP works in multiple mode.
In one mode, you can
take back the data.
In another mode, you
can obfuscate the data.
But often customers do not
want to change the data.
They want to leave
the data as is,
but they want to
identify the data.
And this integration with DLP
enables users do exactly that.
DLP identifies the
data and creates
tags to specify that this
particular column is of type
PII, and is the type of PII.
Now, lastly, we got a lot of
feedback from our customers
that they wanted to
get metadata from all
of their disparate data sources.
So we modified our API to
enable users to provide metadata
from any source.
But we didn't stop there.
We also created open
source connectors,
and we have put them in GitHub.
It's accessible to everyone.
Using those open
source connectors,
users like yourself can ingest
metadata from Hive, Oracle, SQL
Server, Teradata, Redshift,
MySQL, PostgreSQL--
the list continues to grow.
We have also added [INAUDIBLE].
And as you can see, we can also
ingest with these connectors--
we can also ingest technical
metadata from BI tools
like Looker and Tableau.
The end result is that
Data Catalog gives you
a unified view of
all your data assets.
A single pane of glass--
you'll find them all.
A little bit about the
Data Catalog architecture,
because one of the questions
that often comes up
is how robust is the service?
How global is the service?
How scalable is this service?
So we have launched
Data Catalog in GA.
We did that at the end of April.
We have launched the service in
23 different regions and market
agents.
So it's a global service, and
it provides metadata residency
at rest.
And there are many
building blocks.
And the three big
building blocks
are real-time and
batch syncers that
bring metadata from
various sources
and put it in the
Data Catalog, then
the metadata store itself,
which stores all the metadata
in the Data Catalog.
So the metadata store is
just a transaction store.
We use Spanner to build
the infrastructure.
As you know, Spanner is
a globally distributed,
strongly consistent database.
So we have a very
solid foundation.
We also leverage the same
Google search technology that
follows Gmail and Google Drive.
And that gives us search with
access control built into it.
Gmail, as you know, has
more than a billion users,
and so we know that is a
very scalable technology.
So Data Catalog is built on
this very strong foundation.
In terms of innovation, what
we really introduce that is new
here is the concept
of structured tags.
So the traditional catalogs
usually enable tags--
usually enable users
to put on tags.
But those tags are
simple text strings.
And as you'd assume,
it is very hard
to capture complex metadata.
So we innovated, and we
said each tag actually
can be a schematized tag.
But, you know, since
schema is taken for data,
we call them not
a schematized tag
but we call them
structured tags.
So here is an example-- here is
an illustration of how the tags
look like in our catalog.
Each tag has multiple
fields, and each field
is of a different type.
We support five different types.
We support Double, Boolean,
String, Enumerated,
and DateTime.
And as a result, you
can create, for example,
the tags here in this
diagram on the left
are applied at the table level.
The tags on the top are
applied at the column level.
So our structured tags
are supported even
at the column level.
And here is some
illustration of how
the tags can be used because
the user journeys that need
to be supported for example.
You know, one of
the common things
that happens when analysts
come to work is they say, OK,
did last night's ETL
job run successfully?
Do I have fresh data?
And imagine if instead of, you
know, pinging data engineering
and asking them-- if
they could actually
put these structured tags in
the data asset themselves.
So in this illustration, I
show a data ingestion tag.
And analysts, by looking at
it, will know immediately
that the last night's ETL
job was completed normally.
100,000 records were
processed, 100,000 were added,
there were only
40 with warnings,
and there was zero errors.
And they do not need actually,
you know, ping data engineering
and keep asking them
where it stands.
Data governance can
create tags which
let users know what is the
classification of this data.
Is it public?
Is it private?
Is it confidential?
Is it regulatory?
Where in the lifecycle
is this data?
Is it in test, in prod, in dev?
If there is a retention time
that is a constraint on this,
who is the business owner?
What's the corresponding
on-prem data?
So there is a
whole bunch of what
we refer to as business metadata
that users need access to
and there is no easy
way of providing this.
You know, people
often ask me, what's
the competition for
the Data Catalog.
And the answer is
interestingly, you know,
Google Sheets, Excel sheets,
Wiki pages, Confluence pages.
Typically, the metadata is
spread all over the place,
and there is no easy way to
make it available online,
make it searchable.
And our structured tags enable
users to do exactly that.
I have another example
here for data quality.
Now often, one of the big
challenges analysts face
is that they discover
the data asset,
but they have no
idea as to what's
the quality of this data.
Is it actually approved?
Is it usable?
Is it mostly null?
What is the cardinality?
What is the mean, max, median?
Data Catalog tags
enable you to compute
all the data quality
metrics and make
it available as business data.
The PII tags are kind of
self-evident here, right?
So in this example, I have
two fields in the PII.
One is the has_pii which
is of type Boolean,
and it's true here.
The second is type_pii.
For the second column, it
says, hey, it's an SSN.
For the fourth
column, it indicates
that it's an email address.
So the structured tags provide
a very powerful, flexible,
and generic way to capture
all kinds of business metadata
and make it available
to your users.
So let's talk a little bit
more about the structured tags.
If there is a
structure to the tag,
there has to be a way to
specify the structure.
So we have the
concept of templates.
We don't want to call it schema,
so we call them templates.
So on the left, I show
an example of a template
where you can say, OK--
and by the way, all of this
is completely customizable.
So if you as a user want
to create a tag template
and put 5 or 6 or 20 fields
in it, you can do that.
So in this example,
I have this fields
called approved by
data governance,
and it is of type Boolean.
And then I have
data classification,
which is of type Enumerated.
And in this enumerated
type for my example,
I choose to define public,
sensitive, confidential,
and regulatory as
possible choices.
Now, you as a user can
set your own choices.
You can set your own
enumerated types, OK?
So there's a data lifecycle
that's also enumerated type.
The delete by date, you know,
I mentioned a string here,
but actually it can be DateTime
now that we support DateTime.
There is has_pii there.
That it is Boolean.
Those are the templates.
Now on the right side, I
show an example of the tag
that we created
using this template.
So in this case,
approved by data
governance is set to
true data classification,
is set to sensitive, et cetera.
And as for the illustration,
once you have a template,
you can create tags
using that template
in the mold of the template.
And then you attach it to
individual data assets.
So you can think of
this as some sort
of electronic sticky notes.
Those are now applied
to every data asset.
So whenever somebody
looks at a data asset,
they get to see all the
related metadata, right?
Now, how do people
discover the metadata?
So the first thing is,
you know, we have Google.
We like to think we
know how to do search.
So we enable users to
do simple keyword search
so the business user can
simply type a keyword
and find the data asset.
But the power
users among you who
actually want to do the
drill down [INAUDIBLE],,
or the needle in a
haystack way, for them,
we'll also enable facet search
where you can specifically say,
I want to limit my
search to this project
ID or these project IDs.
I want to look at only BigQuery,
or I want to look at only views
where the column
matches a keyword,
or it has certain tags, the
tag, you know, has_pii is true,
or a combination thereof.
You can create a more complex
query by combining with "and"
and "or," et cetera, and "not."
So you have the full power
of the search technology
at your disposal.
OK?
One of the really
important things
that I want to
mention in our tagging
is that everything is
integrated with IAM.
Security is built into Data
Catalog from the get-go.
So we have two personas here.
We have data governor persona.
And let's say in this
case, data governor has
full access to data assets
in project A, B, and C.
And we have another
person, our data analyst.
And data analyst has full access
to data assets in project A,
but metadata read only access
to data assets in project B,
and no access at
all to project C.
Even though all the metadata
resides in the search index,
when the data analyst
looks for data assets,
they see a different view
because in the 500 milliseconds
that we try to discern
something like 98% of the time,
we've done probably
100,000 active checks
on access control checks to
figure out who can see what.
And this is a really,
really important point
for many of our
customers, especially
the financial customers,
banks, et cetera,
because security is paramount.
And you cannot compromise that.
And so as I mentioned,
we have it built into it.
Now, building further on top
of that security framework,
the tags themselves are
also access controlled.
All right, so in
this scenario, we
have data governor
persona who has
access to three different tags.
And the data analyst
persona has access
to only two of those tags
because in many cases,
we have seen customers,
especially the data governance
team, create tags where they
put sensitive information
and they do not want
others to see this.
And Data Catalog
enables you to do that.
So even the tags are also
under access control.
Now, the next thing that I want
to mention is that, you know,
we believe in a
very open system.
We believe that
it's your metadata.
You can do whatever
you want to do with it.
You want to bring in
metadata from other systems,
or you want to take
metadata data out,
we enable you to do that.
And in order for you
to do this in bulk,
as in bringing in large amounts
of metadata from outside
into our search index or
take out the metadata,
we enable APIs.
And we support seven
language libraries
so that you can
create all the action.
Behind every UI,
there is an API call.
So everything is
available through the API.
And many of our
customers actually
have their own front ends also.
And they use the API
to power the backend
because this is a much more
scalable and performing
backend.
And at this point, I would like
to invite Shruti from BlackRock
to share her experience using
Data Catalog, the reasons why
they choose to
partner with Google,
and how they achieve
their objectives.
SHRUTI THAKER: Hi, Shekhar, hi.
I'm Shruti Thaker.
I work in active
equities at BlackRock.
And I'm head of vendor
data and alpha capture.
I'm also the Google
administrator for our Google
Cloud instance in my team.
So why Data Catalog?
Well, when we
started our journey
bringing alternative
data into BlackRock
and making it available
for our investors to use
in their research and analysis.
We started to find that
the data that was coming in
was very different to the more
traditional financial data that
already existed within BlackRock
within the data structures that
were made available to us.
So what we were seeing were lots
of very dynamic schemas, lots
of different
formats, and working
with vendors that really didn't
connect with financial industry
as a rule.
So the data was coming in
lots of different file types
as well.
On the other side, we
had a spectrum of users.
We had people both
geographically diverse,
from San Francisco to Hong
Kong, from Sydney to London,
as well as people who
had different levels
of comfortableness with
how to get to the data.
We had people who were very,
very comfortable just going
into a server, going
to a CLI environment,
finding the file that they need,
pulling it, and analyzing it.
On the other side,
we had lots of users
who really needed
that interface--
that front end which
allowed them to go in
and search for data
using keywords or tags,
and then be able to find that
data, and then work with it.
What we found was that we
really weren't seeing something
that could help us with both of
these issues within BlackRock.
And so we decided to go
and talk to our colleagues
at Google Cloud to see
if there was something
that they could help us with.
So we started talking
to Google Cloud in 2018,
and we explained to them
what we were trying to do.
And luckily for us
at that time, Shekhar
was just putting Data
Catalog into alpha.
So we were able to
get in there and talk
to Shekhar and his
team and explain
what we were trying to do.
And he showed us that it was
possible to find a solution
using Google Data Catalog.
Because the Catalog
was in alpha when
we started working with Google
Cloud, it was possible for us
to both help shape the product
and find a solution that
would work for us in tandem.
One of the great things
about the Data Catalog
is that it's really well
integrated into the Google
Cloud ecosystem.
So when you're looking at one
part of this puzzle, which
is the Data Catalog,
you're not then
having to build APIs
or build connections
into other parts of Google.
It's already
connected to BigQuery.
It's already connected to
storage and to Compute.
So it was quite
easy for us to be
able to come up with an
integrated and complex front
end, which would really provide
our users a really powerful way
to find and analyze data.
We were also able to very
simply create templates,
both on the front
end to start with.
And then as our templates
became more complicated,
we worked with
Shekhar and the team
to put our templates into an
Excel file which we could then
upload directly via Python.
This actually made our
lives a lot easier.
And we were able to create
tags as we wanted them.
We were able to say, OK, well,
we would like asset management
as a tag.
We would also like
different sectors as tags.
And we were able to put them in.
There wasn't anything
that was pre-created,
which really gave us the
freedom that we needed
to develop our own solution.
As the Catalog has moved to
the general access phase,
new functionality
has been added,
including automatic
tagging and tagging
of sensitive information.
We would like to start using
that in the next iteration
of our products.
Following is a short
demo of the product
that we built using Data
Catalog as our engine.
Hi, and welcome to Data Bodega.
Data Bodega is an
application that
was created on GCP which
relies on the GCP Data Catalog
for its core functionality.
Data Bodega allows users to use
an intuitive and user-friendly
interface to try and find all of
the data sets available to them
and to do further simple
analysis where possible.
When someone logs
into Data Bodega,
they'll be able to see all of
the tagged data sets split out
by category into
different sections.
Each one of the files in each
section consists of a data set.
Users can also split by
sectors, regions, or style.
The other way that people
can search the data
is by looking at the intelligent
search on the left-hand side.
Here they can enter a keyword.
Or if they know the
table name or data set,
the names of those table
names or data sets.
Or they can do a filter search.
The filter search allows people
to use commonly thought of tags
and use those to do searches.
For this demo, we're
going to do a search using
the intelligent search.
I'm going to look for
some of this data.
This is data from the last
publicly available census
in the US.
As you can see, we've got two
data sets, the postal codes
and the demographics.
If we click on
geospatial_postalcodes,
it will open up the data set
and show me all of the tables
available there.
As you can see, there's only
a single data table available.
If I click on that, on
the right-hand side,
you will notice that we now
see a preview of the table
as well as some information
that allows the user
to understand how
fresh the data is
and also if they need permission
to the data in GCP or BigQuery,
what project name to
ask for permission for.
You can see that we
can also show people
the top 50 rows of each
data set that is available.
This is refreshed
on a nightly basis.
And the only point
of this is to allow
people to have an
idea of what the data
set looks like, what kind
of numbers are involved,
et cetera.
You can also download this
data set as a CSV if needed.
The other tab available
here is the Analysis tab.
If you click on here, and the
data set has time series data,
there'll be some simple
graphing that can be possible.
You can also, however, open
the data directly in BigQuery
if you have access
already in Tableau.
Or you can download the data
dictionary if that's available.
The way we created
this application is we
went into Data Bodega project
in GCP and called it mosaic.
And we went and created a
bunch of data tag templates.
Now the reason we
created so many
was that we needed
to have multiselect
on some of our tags, such
as region or country.
And the only way to do that was
to create a region or country
tag template and have
Boolean yes or no on there.
Fortunately we were
able to work with Google
to help us create the tag
templates in a format in Excel
which we were able to then just
upload into GCP using Python.
This made things a
lot easier and quicker
than creating the tag
templates on the front end.
We then went through all of
our data sets in BigQuery
and tagged all of them
using these tag templates.
The next step is to start
auto-tagging data sets
as they come in and they're
onboarded using various data
attributes that are
made available to us
at the point of onboarding.
This is a quick
foray into what can
be built using Data Catalog.
We found it incredibly
useful to be
able to go in and connect and
allow users to go in and search
for data without knowing
the names of the date set
or knowing particular
attributes of the data set
and only knowing roughly the
topic that they're looking for.
We hope to work
further with Google
to create more functionality and
more depth to our product using
Data Catalog.
SHEKHAR BAPAT:
Thank you, Shruti,
for that wonderful
presentation and the demo.
So what are the next things
you can do as a user?
The first thing I
want to point out
is that you can launch
Data Catalog right away.
There is no setup required.
Data Catalog indexes all the
metadata in the background
continuously, so
all you need to do
is to go to this
particular link,
the console.cloud.google.com.
Go to Data Catalog.
You can select a project that
you wanted to start using.
Just enable the API,
and all the data assets
are already discoverable
to you, just
with a simple keyword search or
the powerful search language.
You can also use DLP to auto-tag
PII data in the Data Catalog.
The DLP integration is
available through the DLP UI.
It is also available
through the API.
And this link gives
you the details
of how to do this to tag
PII data at the table level
as well as at column level.
And lastly, if you are
one of the users who
has data scattered in all
of these different silos,
and you're finding
it really, really
hard to discover
those data assets,
you can use one
of our connectors.
And all the connectors are
listed in the Google's GitHub
repo.
You can download them.
They are open-source
connectors, and you can
start using them right away.
Happy data discovery journey.